My favorite really is a nonprofit.
I had a young woman come to me,
I guess it's three years ago,
and she came in my office and sat down
and take my entrepreneurship courses and
she said,
you know,
in New York City public schools,
there are 300 schools that are
elementary that do not have playgrounds
for children.
I'm going to fix that.
And they just sat there and kind of
nodded and said,
that's interesting how you're going to
do that.
And she said,
I don't know,
but I'm going to do it.
Did you spent a year studying it,
going around and taking pictures,
building a case that this was something
that really children should have.
Three years later,
that young lady has raised over $10
million.
She's already completed 20 playgrounds
in New York City,
has 20 some more in the pipeline under
construction.
So I look at somebody like that and she
has the skill to new or anything she
wants,
but I just am overwhelmed with the fact
that she could go out there and do it
just with that spirit.
And I celebrate her every time I see
her.
Uh,
we also have a company that we launched
called Recycle Bank,
which is a,
a company that's done just phenomenally
well.
And it came out of our program and I
worked very closely with that student,
a Ron Gonan,
and it's built into something very
special.
You know,
there were awarding people for
recycling,
and it's a rewards program and they're
having a dramatic effect in the cities
that they're entering.
And I see a lot of growth.
We just have endless numbers of these
wonderful young people.
And I get up every day just a Sullivan
[inaudible].